pas par exemple un message d'une
personne qui avait 20 ans et ces coucous
ça va là où la webcam ça te dit réponse
te plaît pour pour mon enquête entre
guillemets j'ai dû m'inscrire me faire
un faux profil d'une gamine d'une enfant
de 13 ans et je me suis inscrit sur
plusieurs sites sur trois sites et sur
ses trois sites à chaque fois je
recevais sans demander sans aller vers
les gens je recevais des messages des
adultes en ce qui concerne les demandes
d'amis on arrive au problème principal
de ce genre de sites ce qui explique
pourquoi c'est aussi malsain la moitié
des ajouts sont faits par des adultes de
plus de 18 ans allant jusqu'à
régulièrement 25 ans je recevais des
messages des adultes 50 50 c'était 50 %
du temps des adultes de plus de 20 ans
et le reste c'était plus du 14 18 ans à
chaque fois c'était des messages très en
vue et des demandes plus ou moins
plus ou moins graves ou que ça allait
tout simplement du veux tu es ce que tu
veux passer ton se tapotant sky jusqu'à
a demandé si je voulais être rémunéré en
échange de ce soir est forcément avoir
des relations intimes quoi à chaque
discussion je rappelle clairement que
j'ai seulement 13 ans pour être sûr
qu'il sait lâche théorique que j'ai 90 %
du temps on me dit que ce n'est pas
grave que ça ne le dérange pas les
autres renchérit en disant que je ne
fais pas mon âge que je suis tout de
même très jolie bref de la bonne drive
bien lourde sous des personnes dont j'ai
pas la vidéo un certain nico qui qui lui
sait a fait un tableau de chasse complet
de 2 c de ses victimes et s'était exilé
plusieurs de 12 ans plusieurs de 11 ans
plusieurs de 15 ans plusieurs de 14 ans
et sa souris qu'ils étaient habitués de
ces sites là en fait on nous apprend
beaucoup dans la vie de tous les jours
ne pas parler à des inconnus
mais sur internet bassée
ça doit être la même chose et pourtant
nous l'apprend pas où on fait pas assez
attention par rapport à ça et c'est
dommage que d'un côté bah faudrait que
ce soit les parents qui en parler fort
et peut-être aussi que ce soit chez pas
les profs ou kiki qui en parle le
conseil après c'est valable à tous les
sites et toutes les réseaux sociaux
c'est vraiment dedans par les hommes et
vidéo en général j'en parle c'est que
s'ils sont sur des sites de rencontres
pour ados ils sont forcément autre part
et la plupart du temps ils sont là où il
ya eu il ya le plus d'interaction avec
les jeunes mais vraiment sur ce match at
et skype c'est c'est là où ils ont
facilement ce qu'ils veulent avec les
calmes avec les sescam les les les nude
sur snap chatte et c'est ce qu'ils
veulent et c'est pour ça qu'ils qui
demande innocemment entre guillemets si
tu as un chat si tu as un sky pour
discuter mais ils viennent forcément à
ce qu ils veulent quoi
[Musique]